la réserve des fêtes 2000 hectares et
cette forêt se divise en trois parties
la forêt de niaouli ou bien eucalyptus
aquatique et il y a aussi
la forêt dégradée et la forêt secondaire
humide
c'est un arbre sacré c'est sa qu'on
utilise pour faire les totems pour faire
les poteaux sacrificielles
on est tous des pêcheurs c'est avec cet
arbre qu'on
fait les
bateaux pour aller pêcher dans la mer
Balzac 10 ans tu peux faire une pyrogue
avec ça c'est un
aussi les plantes qui s'appelle aurait
d'éléphant le fruit de cette plante on
prend ça par exemple après les cyclones
après le débordement de l'eau là on a
plus rien et on prend le fruit de cette
plante pour manger
c'est la quatrième plante espèce
endémique locale
c'est le repas locatif
ça sert aussi pour le bois de
construction
néphila vert ça s'appelle si c'est
l'araignée les plus antique
vous est au marché